welcome everyone um i'm priyana tarajan
an astrophysicist on the faculty in the
departments of astronomy and physics at
yale i also serve as the current
director of yale's flagship
interdisciplinary program the frankie
program in science and humanities
i'm delighted to have you all attend
today's wonderful talk by neuroscientist
and author mariano sigmund as part of
our ongoing mapping as knowing series
i want to first start by recognizing the
generosity of mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie for endowing this
program and many other activities at
yale
as a quick point of reminder since we
are recording this event i would like to
request you all to mute your videos and
microphones
uh please go ahead and submit your
questions for our speaker through the q
a feature
dr thai camp and i will relay this these
questions to him after the talk
so coming to our speaker today um
dr mariano sigmund is an eminent
neuroscientist with
well over 150 publications and some of
the most prestigious scientific journals
he's extremely research active he's also
very passionate about experimentation
and has worked on an unusually large set
of
collaborators that might sound really
peculiar and intriguing magicians chess
masters musicians athletes and visual
artists to bring his knowledge of
neuroscience to different aspects of
human culture and activity and apply it
in different contexts he has
participated
um several times in the ted global
events in vancouver and in one of these
instances he participated uh with dan uh
really
in his conferences he teaches how the
mind works and what lessons we can learn
about decision making leadership team
management
personal development or creative skills
and his presentations always
end up with sort of a high level of
participation uh from the audience
through experiments
and gamification
dr sigman obtained his degree in physics
from the university of buenos aires his
doctorate in neuroscience in new york
and he did a post-doc in cognitive
sciences at the college de france in
paris in 2016 he was awarded the po11
medal from the pontifical academy of
science which is a major science prize
uh and previous winners include stephen
hawking and many notable nobel prize
winners beyond the academy his research
has had practical implications uh for
medicine
for treatments uh clinical treatments uh
for example in the diagnosis of
vegetative or autistic patients
and he's also had a lot of impact in
education with
effective interventions to improve
decision making
and learning in schools throughout latin
america
and in art uh with a project at the
morphology of the look that has been
exhibited now in new york austria moscow
mexico japan and was part of the 2017
venice biennale
he's also developed an extensive career
in the public dissemination of science
that includes
multitudes of tv programs hundreds of
articles published in different
editorial media he's also the author of
the bestseller the secret life of the
mind
i highly recommend this book absolutely
fell in love with it it's just
beautifully written
before turning over the floor to him i
would just like to remind you all about
our learning by doing project please do
consider submitting your videos to our
collection of simple science experiments
and
our final talk in the inference series
will be given by physicist kyle cranmer
next week on
december 15th at 3 p.m so without
further ado i would like to turn over to
uh mariano welcome and we wish we could
have welcomed you in person in new haven
uh we had been postponing um
get your talk hoping that we could get
you in person but then ultimately
decided that we didn't want to wait any
longer and that we're dying to hear you
so look forward to your talk
thank you
thank you so much priya for for this uh
such a warm
introduction and
i also would very much like to be able
to be there i went to new haven when i
was a child my my aunt she was a
neurologist
and she worked there at yale actually
and i went there as a child and and i
you know how we build these
child memories of these places you know
as a bit mythical like for me my aunt
was a huge intellectual and a great
neurologist and
and this place was the place where you
know great scientists went and i've
never gone back interesting like i've
gone to i spent many years in the us in
academia and i've been in many of the
main universities but but i just
brought this memory that for some reason
i never came back to yale and i i very
much hope will have the opportunity i
would very much wish to
to go there again so yeah we look
forward to your visit in person this
this has brought me a very a very uh
emotional memory from from my childhood
okay so so i'm gonna speak about
decision making
but because the i mean this this uh
series builds on the relation between
mapping and knowledge
i thought it would be interesting to
begin
not so much with the science of decision
but the other way around how science has
helped us
make decisions in in difficult domains i
think this has been often a role of
science to bring
a relevant data for having informed
policies and informed decisions and this
has happened in all in all fields of
knowledge and of course this includes
neuroscience and especially the the
bridge or the relation between
neuroscience and medicine
and priya you mentioned
like the work we've done
on diagnosis of vegetative state
patients i think this is a very clear
case where many years ago
there was not much that could be done
because essentially we were looking at
devoid and technology has changed in a
way that now we have the capacity
to be able to infer
thoughts of other people by looking at
their brains
and this is a technology that may be
flashy and interesting but it gets
really relevant when this is the only
way that we have to communicate
with some people and and this happens in
in three very peculiar domains one is is
patients come at those patients or
patients in vegetative states where
we it looks like they are unconscious
but we are really not sure if they're
unconscious they do not express
consciousness but of course that doesn't
mean they do not have consciousness
another example i'll be showing some
data is on babies
when they're pre-verbal and they cannot
communicate their minds and as parents
we do like all what we can to understand
what they feel what they want what they
suffer what they desire and we do this
exercise of complicated inference where
once again technology now can give us a
good hand and the third case which i
will not be speaking today is dreams
which also remains i think one of the
very interesting frontiers of knowledge
in human neuroscience so let me start
with work done by adrian owen this is an
extremely classic paper it has now 25
years
um and what you're seeing there is is
the
image the brain image by fmri
of the group of people this is the
average image and it's been thresholded
so the pattern of course would be much
more complicated but what you see on
your left of the screen here
is what activates when someone imagines
that plays tennis and this is nothing
special about tennis it has to do with
motor actions so what you see here
lighted is a region in the brain called
this supplementary motor area
and this is a region that is involved
with the coordination of movement but
even if we do not enact these movements
and we just imagine them then this
region also plays the same role it's
like a music director that's directing
the concert without its sounding
and on the right you see how the brain
of a person
activates when they close their eyes and
they imagine they are walking in their
houses or they are walking in the yale
campus or they are going from their
house to their work we have a very
significant capacity this comes from our
ancestors rodents and old mammals to
navigate in space and there are brain
regions that are dedicated to this i'm
not so interested now in the in the
brain science of these
specific functions what i'm interested
in is that now if you see this from an
engineering perspective now what we have
is a utility a tool a technology that
somehow we can tell very rudimentary
what the person is thinking
just by looking at their brains so if i
would let you know you know think
whatever you want either that you're
playing tennis or that you're you know
walking in your in your in your house
then i could tell with very high
probability what is actually what you're
thinking just looking at your brain
again this is not very useful i could
just ask you that but once again we come
to the vegetative stay patients we
cannot ask them about their thoughts but
somehow we can prompt them to make
thoughts and then ask what happens and
so
the genetic state patients they have in
you know in
in the public scene for for many years
now and the reason for this there are
two reasons the first one is a purely
medical reason which is that
20 years ago these patients arrived in a
coma to a hospital and their likelihood
of survival was very low now they
survive but they do so in a situation
which once again is a huge mystery about
what goes on it's a situation which of
course leads to a lot of of ethical
problems a lot of suffering and so
adrian owen redid this experiment now
with one patient one patient that had
been
five years completely uncommunicated and
with the idea that she was unable to
make explicit thoughts
what if she could but she could not
communicate them could it be that
reading their minds by mri we could
detect that and that's what adrienne did
what he found is that when he asked this
patient to
imagine that she paid tennis or that she
moved apparently she heard this message
and she reacted and she enacted this
motion and the same thing with a spatial
navigation of course we do not know
whether they're conscious about these
thoughts it could be that they're
unconscious but at least we know that
they understand something and they can
react to that and once you have this
tool this is an engineering device that
you can use now as a binary
communication device
so you can say whenever you want to say
yes imagine that you play tennis
whenever you want to say no then imagine
that
you are walking in your house and as any
communication device you want to
calibrate it and you want to collaborate
with things that you know so you ask
questions like are you a woman the
answer is true so you expect the answer
to be yes are you younger than 23 and
the answer is no
do you have three siblings the answer is
no and so on and once you have
calibrated this this communication
device which is
far from perfect but it's also much
better than chance then you can start
asking the questions that you would like
to ask
are you suffering what would you want
what would you wish what would you what
would you want us to do and then we go
to a completely different sphere it's
the sphere of ethics but it's one that's
nurtured or that can be fueled by data
that can be provided by science this is
of course a very important but also very
tough example let me now give you a much
candied one one which i think it's it's
it's uh we all at least for all of us
that are parents we we've gone through
this experience so what you're seeing
here is again the same strategy as i
showed you before first the brain of a
person in which the experiment is so to
say easy and this experiment is just the
person listening to sentences so it
could be
you can imagine this as what happens in
your brain as you're listening as you're
listening me to speak what happens is
that you see these pattern activations
in these two big regions this is the
auditory cortexes and of course the
record is activated when you hear sound
also interestingly i cannot go in the
details of this but you see even if this
is an old paper we were pushing the
limits of of temporal resolution you you
may know that fmri is very is pretty
decently good in spatial resolution you
can get these maps which have like
millimeter
resolution but the temporal resolution
is very low and cognition happens in a
fraction of a second and suddenly you
have you know a
tool that actually had a resolution of a
few seconds and so we were in the
frontier of this and what you see here
in different colors is not the amount of
activity which is what you typically see
in a format image but the timing of
activity and you see going from this is
measured by a by like the magnetic
signal which is the mri response and the
phase of the we can measure the phase of
this of this
of this signal by the convolving the the
the response function and we could
compute with this or we could infer the
temporality of the responses and what
you see once again this is this is a
very fast summary of something that
could be the entire talk and you see
that there's early activation in the
auditory cortex which projects to this
region in the frontal left cortex very
famous region you may have heard about
it called the broca region it's been
broken by neurologists in french
neurologist proca
and this region is known to be relevant
and it's one of the very highly
specialized regions in the brain which
is specialized for the articulation of
of language so if if you you have a
fascia which means that you can
understand language but you cannot
produce language then typically you will
have lesions in the broker
in people that have fascist catholicism
in the broca region now if you've been
following the logic of what they said
there's something that may seem a bit
strange because i'm saying this is the
brain the activations in brain of people
listening to sentences and yet they're
activating one region which is known to
be very specialized for the production
of sentences which they're not making
they're just listening well as it
happens
with something that we've discovered and
it's my we the field i mean not not me
or my lab the entire field is that there
is a whole system of resonance called
the mirror system
in the human brain and in the mammal
brain which is that essentially we
internalize all the actions we perceive
by enacting them somehow so on a way
when we hear two sentences we are also
producing internally and silently
descendants a little bit like i showed
you in the previous slide when i said
when you imagine that you're playing
tennis you're not moving the muscles yet
you're enacting the entire motor concert
now the question is what happens with
young babies when they listen to
sentences because it's not that they do
not they will not you know produce
languages that they can't i mean they
have three months they are still you
know they have to quadruple their
lifetime to arrive to the moment in
which they'll begin producing their
first words and sentences
so
is a preverbal baby very far from the
moment of the initiation of production
of language
silently producing language this was a
philosophical question one that was not
amenable to science now we have proxies
we cannot completely answer this
question but we have good ways of
addressing this question which is
repeating this exact experiment in
babies and asking whether is there
broccoli region already being activated
the region that actually works in the
production of sentences and now what you
have is a summary of three month old
babies once again for those that
have not experienced with babies they're
very very far from producing language
and yet on a way they're trying and this
was to me i would like to present
something which for me is very important
here which is in the moment i like this
this experiment i did just before i had
my first child
and and i thought it was very important
because i think in a way a very
essential thing of parenthood is that we
try to detect the struggles that our
children may be undergoing and we help
them so if they're struggling with
walking we'll give them a hand if they
are struggling with eating will help
them on that
but of course they are going through a
million of
struggles that we will never see
because they are opaque they are silent
and i really like this experiment not
only because of its scientific
pertinence because i thought it'd
communicate me better it's kind of of
what i like most of neuroscience which
is this capacity of getting closer to
the people that we would like eventually
to get closer so on a way what this told
me kind of short
story and a bit exaggerated of this
result is that in the same way that the
nine month old baby is trying to walk
and they are struggling a
three-month-old baby although this is
silent they're trying to speak they're
trying to make their first words and so
i accompanied and i walked with my son
on this particular process
so this is just a way on also on how
science
may begin us informing on on policies
for education now not education in
school but maybe even more relevant form
of education which is parental location
so this is the first part of my talk and
and it has kind of a different flavor
because once again it's not so much the
neuroscience of decisions but it's the
neuroscience that can help us or will
give us information to make better
decisions now i would like to go to like
a completely different
space of decisions which is the ones we
do not have this technology and this
much information the majority of the
decisions we make which is somehow we
have the information that we have scarce
information often not enough of
sometimes even like no information and
we have to make the best educated guess
from what we have so let me give you a
first examples of what we humans do when
we are confronted with this type of
decisions and then uh we'll go into the
science of it and then we'll go on to
how we can improve some of the of the
biases and then some irrationalities
that we tend to make in these decisions
so this is a very classic experiment i
love this experiment and i would like to
do it with you on stage would be much
more interesting because we would sense
it on a much in a much better way
but it was it's a very classic
demonstration the first kind of
scientific paper was published by eric
howard and ramachandran at usucsd
university california san diego the
question is like these are two shapes
one is bubba
and the other one is kiki okay so one is
boba and the orange you know which one
is which but the task for you decision
makers is to tell me which is which you
can do this in the chat if you want so
you get a feeling if you kind of know if
you have a public chat if you do then
you could do it and then you may have
kind of a public sense of of the
agreement that there is in the response
of this typically 98 or 99 percent of
the people
agree that this is kiki and this is buba
and this is quite interesting because it
feels like completely obvious as if it
could not be in a different way yet when
we're asked like why is the case it's
just very hard because there's no reason
for that some people do see a k here but
if i would say tt instead of kiki then
it would be the same same thing and the
reason is known the reason is that when
we make sounds we move the mouth
and when we move the mouth the mouth
builds different shapes so when i go
like o or u those are actually they're
called rounded vowels and so we
think that these sounds correspond to
rounded shapes instead when we make like
these
sounds in which the pale
contracts in a sharp way like like two
like
then we imagine that these sounds are
kind of attacking consonants and are the
ones that have sharp angles so this is
when when i say like there is this
correspondence by no way i mean that we
are making this conscious logical
inference i'm saying the brain is doing
this calculation we're completely
unaware of it it biases our decisions in
an extremely predictable and reliable
way yet we are completely unaware of
this entire process
now this looks like a game and it
doesn't look very important but let me
give you an example which i think it's
it's much it's much more relevant and
you'll see how these same ideas start
forging our decisions domains in which
we maybe would not like them to do so
and so here this is once again i i
mentioned alexander todorov he's in
princeton
um and i didn't point to a specific
paper because it's kind of a collection
of papers and this is my own
demonstration from from history so he's
the reference that you can look at any
of his many papers he's been showing how
we make
judgments about people of all sorts from
facial expressions and the way i like to
frame this experiment is imagine you
have a suitcase with like the most
important things in your life
actually an interesting experiment is
what would you put in this particular
suitcase like what are the most
important things in your life that you
put you know in a in a small space but
imagine you do have so and for some
strange reason it doesn't matter here
you need to leave this suitcase with the
most important things in your life and
you you you know you're confronted with
with this situation you have to respond
very rapidly and you have to decide like
there's these three persons here you can
think this as an investment problem you
have your money you choose what bank to
put it on and each of this is one bank
this is like the technical way of
thinking this experiment the more real
way would be you have something a real
thing and you have to give it to one of
these three people and the question is
to look who you would give
to and here it's not so such a sharp
distribution as we saw before but there
is also a very significant trend that's
observed in children and adults in
america and europe all over different
cultures and so on which is that the
majority of the people prefer to give it
to the person in the center
and the reasons why they do not give it
much some people do give it to the
person in the right and some people do
the person the left but the reasoning
beyond this particular decision
is that
the person they write we do not trust
him so much like we have the impression
that we may come back and ask for a
suitcase and he may go you know what i
like your suitcase and i will not give
it back to you and we do not want to go
through this confrontation with this
particular person
the reason why the majority of the
people do not give it to the person on
the left is very different is we think
he's like so naive
that he will give it back to us but
maybe he will give it to anyone and he
will lose it or he will be stole our
suitcase now the interesting thing is i
mean you i think you get the point that
the majority of us do make these very
fast and rapid inferences and the
interesting point is that we have no
idea about these people we have not a
single piece of evidence about how they
would behave
yet we make conclusions and conclusions
in which the majority of the people
is highly confident
really trusts this impression
of what the right action should be it
could be
it's possible it's not impossible that
the faces of actually you can see also
that this it's the same person that has
been only changed the curvature of the
mouth and the eyebrows and so on now it
could be
that there is a correlation between
people's faces and people's attitudes i
mean this is not impossible but it's not
true i mean the nobel prize candyman
also in princeton
it has shown many times that these
correlations actually do not hold in any
way and so the conclusions that we make
so strongly by people's appearances are
completely ungrounded and they lead to
completely wrong decisions in which we
deeply trust
now this
the example of kiki and buba was kind of
a game this is very relevant because for
instance it's known that the face of a
person shapes elections so if i were to
show you two candidates of like a
completely unknown county of of
australia and ask you who you think will
win you'll be kind of at 50 55 or 60
and what this means is that only by the
information in the face is what the
voters are using to make their choices
because you have no idea of who is a
democrat who is a republican who is
progressive who is conservative who has
a good history no no information at all
only with information of the face you
can make this a sort of conclusion also
it's very well known in human resources
the majority of the people
decide who to hire on the first 500
milliseconds of an interview and then
they spend 20 minutes only to justify
the decision that they have
already made so
i've given you two examples i could give
you 20 i mean there are millions of
they're finding samples you know and how
make this kind of
of of of the what's consistent about all
these examples is how we are very
stereotypical
people call it irrational i don't think
it's irrational because there is
rationality only that we are doing
rationality on the wrong grounds and on
the wrong evidence and on the wrong
information but there's a kind of of a
smart inference process but that takes
us with very high confidence to wrong
conclusions now what i would like to do
is to tell you how this process builds
how we actually build these intuitions
and once again i'm building i'm bringing
you some classics of the field uh this
is an experiment that you see now has 20
something years it was done by by bejara
and damasio very very famous experiment
in which they tried to understand
how we construct these hunches and these
unconscious intuitions and i think it's
a very beautiful experiment so let me
tell you exactly how it goes it so it's
it's also an investment experiment and
and the way it goes is that people are
given two decks
and these decks have payoffs and these
payoffs can be either positive or
negative you can win money or you can
lose money so it's kind of a simulation
of you have to choose between two
portfolios in in in these stocks you can
choose between them and sometimes you'll
win sometimes you lose and you'll try to
do some statistical learning to
understand on average uh what's the
right policy and that's what people do
they choose from one they win so they
persist this is very typical then they
win again they persist and
we make this inference that if we've won
there's no reason to explore which is
not optimal but that's what people do if
you're winning here you're very unlikely
to go elsewhere eventually you lose and
then people do the country they over
switch and so they go to the other deck
and they they play here for the while
and then they lose and they switch and
so on
and after
an hour of play or something they reach
this moment here which is the conceptual
moment it happens that one of the decks
has a highest average of return than the
other one so this is what's called the
correct choice because it's the one that
on average if you continue playing on
this
uh
regardless of the stochasticity which
you cannot control it is the policy that
will give you a higher expected value so
in the end of this many trials people
choose from the right deck and when you
ask them why they are doing so they go
they explain exactly what i just showed
you well you know you win you lose but
on average this one is better than the
other one so they have understanding
they understood the problem perfectly
well what is interesting is is how is
the path to this particular moment and
some trials sorry some trials before
that there is a moment that the master
calls the hunch moment which is the
following people
play from the right deck
and they if you ask them what they are
doing they say well i'm playing from
this one
i'm choosing from the right why
don't no i have like this feeling that
that's the right thing to do but i
cannot tell you why i mean it's just
kind of a gut feeling a hunch
so there you understand the genesis of
the back feelings they have nothing
esoteric nothing mystical nothing
irrational it's a full-blown statistical
learning process
which yet has not come into words and so
the brain has learned something and
there is no mystery in white has learned
something because it had the statistical
information to learn it but this
knowledge as the majority of the
knowledge we have cannot yet be
explained in a way that we can teach it
in a lecture it's not explicit knowledge
it's implicit knowledge so with this i
would like to give you a feeling of what
intuitions are intuitions are are
essentially a form of learning
statistical learning of different
domains and different this and different
scenarios and different portions of the
universe which yet we have not made
to explicit knowledge now there is an
even more interesting phase which is
what damasio calls the prejudge which is
the following in this phase people as
you see are choosing on average a little
bit more from from the correct than from
the wrong deck but they don't even know
they are doing that so if you ask them
what they are doing they will tell you
i'm just picking a chance like i'm going
one and the other one i'm trying to
learn there's like no information no
structure that's not what they're doing
they're picking more from the right one
the brain has catched this information
this has not yet come in terms of body
expressions of wrong and right decisions
so there's not even this information
but and but they they do have this
information which then builds into a
hunch and then builds into conceptual
knowledge and the second thing i would
like to go on on this kind of fast sweep
through decisions and the idiosyncrasies
and the typical things that we do wrong
and when they are right and so on by the
way let me tell you something which i
think i mean there's there's no way to
respond
completely this particular answer but
something that typically comes into a
very popular question so to say
is what's the right way to decide by the
right way i mean in terms of category of
ways of making decisions and a classical
split is between people that think that
you should follow your heart or your
intuitions and other people that think
that you have kind of to go all the way
in your decisions to write it down to
the last decimal and calculate all what
you can and i think that this tells us
very clearly when
conscious and are good and when they are
bad they're good in domains in which we
do have a lot of
statistical information and there are
some domains that this is true for the
majority of the people one typical
example is social knowledge
we all have a lot of experience on how
people behave
and so social knowledge
rightly works on the ground of
intuitions and it will be complicated to
choose who you'd like to spend your life
and so on by you know very detailed
calculations although algorithms now are
trying to do so for us but the best
resource we may have for this highly
variable problem highly dimensional that
cannot be reduced to simple calculation
is to use broad approximate statistical
learning
other decisions like piloting a plane or
doing surgery of course we want a very
highly precise and educated and large
rational decision-making so this also
tells like
the typical fallacy that some people
think that they have very good
intuitions and this is never true some
people also think that they have very
bad intuitions this is also not true
people have good intuitions for certain
domains in which they are educated
statistically and they have bad
intuitions for domains in which they are
naive so a tennis player will have good
intuitions in tennis maybe a farmer will
have good intuitions on weather because
that's something that's relevant for
them and they've looked at them a lot
and so on and different people have good
intuitions about different domains
now last thing i would like to show you
is the idea of of confidence and this on
the questions we can go more on this and
once again i'm going to make a very very
short excursion a very short trip
to this particular domain let me just
have water sorry
i like this quote by william saying that
this idea that
confidence should be we should be
confident when when we know a lot about
something but that's not what happens
that's what i show you here we tend to
be very confident when we know nothing
and so we just get you know glimpses of
the data but because this is all the
data there is we forget that there's a
lot of ignorance and so we are extremely
confident by spikes of data
and so this is captured by these ideas
confidence is what we have before we
know a problem because when we know a
problem we know the complexity of the
problem and we know that we should
temper our confidence we may understand
more but the first thing we discover is
not understanding but also the universe
of ignorance and the previous
demonstration i think there is we have
ourselves my lab of demonstrations but
there is a this demonstration by renee
which i really like and i thought also
in this mapping symposium it was
interesting also to bring this different
technology which you may be i mean it's
it's also pretty popular now it's called
tms transcranial magnetic stimulation it
works through faraday law so there's a
very
rapid magnetic field that's induced and
this this induces a current it's a very
weak current but it's enough to make a
part in the brain that can do different
things one thing is these poles could be
in the motor cortex so you can you know
you can move your hand and this is very
intriguing because you feel a little bit
like a puppet because there's someone
that's actually controlling directly
from your your brain and moving your
hand you can also go on to language
regions and you know induce the
production of language but also you can
just produce or build noise in the brain
so kind of a scattered current that what
we'll do is bring noise and so if this
conjecture is true
then there is kind of a very
a anti-intuitive a prediction which is
that as you increase the noise in a
problem then you know less and you will
perform worse
but you will be more confident
and this is a typical situation in which
people we recognize these people tend to
be very confident in highly volatile
scenarios once again because they ignore
the variance and then there are very
strong spikes of data which they grab
and they feel very attached to this
particular
subset of the data so what you have here
is a performance on a perceptual task it
doesn't matter the details and as you go
higher in the bar this is b prime which
is kind of the measure statistical
measure of of the performance and this
is different people and what you see is
people vary in performance and this on
blue is the average and this is yet not
too interesting then you put noise into
the brain and you ask what happens with
performance in this particular person
you put noise in the visual cortex what
happens is that people do words and this
is what you'd expect this is just kind
of a not very interesting but at least
the method works you make people do
something and you see that in every
single subject
they do worse when you're injecting
noise then the the black condition
actually there's also it's kind of a
control because there's the same sound
and distance situation but there's no
pulse of current
and now the question is what happens
with confidence and you can see the
comparison here which is that in a
situation in which people do worse which
is the red one people are more confident
so this person is doing worse he or she
is more confident this one is doing
worse but she's more confident and the
same truth for every single person
except for this one here so you see once
again a demonstration of an idea which i
think is very interesting and can be
mapped to a to a to a simple concept
which is we tend to be very confident
when we know nothing about something
because we know nothing about the
ignorance that we have about this
particular space and this is what
happens very often in decision making
which is that we have to make a decision
this decision involves many different
spheres of knowledge we are just looking
at a particular subset of the data we do
logic here we do good inference here and
then we are very convinced but then
someone else is looking at a different
portion of the data and we are also
doing good logic on this particular
portion of the data but ignoring the
rest of the existence of the data and so
they come up with a very different
conclusions and this builds to what
we've seen now these days which is that
people suddenly cannot understand each
other and they come to completely
different conclusions where the world
seems to be completely polarized to a
point that people seem not to be able to
speak one to the other one so i want to
go there on on like my last slides is on
how we can correct this once we
understand this phenomena how we can
correct and it turns out to be that
there is an extremely simple solution
not rocket science very very simple
solution
zero technology
which is a significant game changer
which can improve a lot the decisions
that we make in simple decisions like
you know making you know easy calls but
also in the most complicated decisions
of our lives so this comes from from an
experiment that we did on a huge
audience this was done in a basket
stadium with 10 000 people what i will
show you
is that um
what we had the idea that we are trying
to probe here
is that
if
if the hypothesis is as i told you that
people make bad decisions because they
only look at subsets of the data then
there is an easy way of correcting this
which is putting people together because
together they are sampling at different
portions of the data and so they are
getting a better understanding of the
errors of reasoning that they're not
that they're making because of you know
looking at partial data or or making
conclusions very rapidly and so on and
so there's a simple idea which is that
if you get together with people to think
about the problem then you'll come up
with better decisions not just better in
quality but also more equine emails and
more balanced decisions and so this is
what we wanted to do and so what we
asked these people to make decisions and
then we brought them together in groups
of three and five people this is very
numbers very important i'll explain the
second why and then people dismayed
together this call this decision and
then they had the opportunity to change
their mind and our question was very
simple what happens in this you can see
this kind of a as a filtering process
like a course grading process you have
an idea then you kind of have a kernel
like in deep learning you have a kernel
of different peoples and you lose
statistical information but somehow you
gain resolution or you gain a precision
sorry you lose resolution you can
precision and the question is what
happens
and so
we did this experiment which is a as i
said the i think remains the biggest
public essential uh experiment in
decision making
it was very beautiful because there was
a particular noise you see here on the
right how it went like each each here
which one of this is a group of people
that were
conversating about things sometimes like
kind of easy things to conversate but
also sometimes very difficult and things
that we struggle a lot to put into words
and to discuss with other people so the
first part of the experiment is very
simple it was kind of approximate
questions and this and this we wanted it
to be a model of like the majority of
the decisions we make we have partial
information so one question could be how
many cities are there in the world with
a population larger than 1 million or
the question could be how many times do
the beetles say yesterday in the song
yesterday or the question to be how many
goals were scored in the last football
or soccer world cup or the question
could be how many airports are there in
the us for all these questions you have
an idea you know more or less how many
they are but of course you do not have
the exact answer and if you think these
problems as investment
investment problems the more precise
your calculation then the more likely
that you will make a better call and so
people
made their call which i mean you you can
do yourself you can give a try here we
cannot play the game i mean if we were
together then i would do this experiment
with you i would ask you you know to
think about it then to get together in
groups and so on but that's something
that unfortunately we cannot do
here so the answer for this one
particular is 496. and so what what we
did is um
is
we looked at what happened and i
something i'd like to tell you is that
data here people wrote this in in in
you know in a paper they use pencils and
paper so nothing sophisticated and
actually our data set were huge
garbage guns a garbage bag sorry huge
garbage bags with thousands of papers
which we took and then we digitalized
and so on and we converted this into
science so what you see here is kind of
what was the norm by then and the norm
was a very simple simple statistical
um um
idea which is that
if people are unbiased which is true for
a certain class of problems then the
more people you get the better it will
be your result essentially because there
will be noise canceling it's this is not
a statement about people it's a
statement about statistics so it's
convergence to the to the mean so some
people will think there's more some
people will think less and as you get
more and more people these things will
cancel and eventually you converge to me
now because there were many questions
and questions referred had different
units they refer to different things you
have this expressed in terms of
normalized errors and you see that it
does not converge to zero and the reason
it does not converge to zero is because
people in many questions they are biased
and so the majority of the people
think that there's more than actually
there was so there was less so they
either overestimate consistently or they
underestimate consistently and and this
is something that cannot be cancelled by
aggregating more and more people and the
question was what happens when we get
people together so there was like
imagine there was like 1 000 people so
we've got 1 000 boats and then we get
them we can look like coarse grainy as i
said before we can get them in groups of
five so now we have only 200 groups but
each group has a better
decision and so the question is is this
course running efficient or not and the
answer is it's highly efficient so you
see it here which is that actually
when people get together they converge
to a decision which is much better than
the decision they had before getting
into the group
and this made a lot of noise although it
may seem very simple because there was
kind of a very strong belief if you
think this from a statistical
perspective once again for a system to
be sound statistically you want
particles to be independent the moment
they get correlated because they stand
they start talking to each other then
you lose statistical information and
then you get kind of redundant and then
instead of having a thousand votes you
have less bones but what we were showing
here is actually that
the value of conversation actually was
greater than what you lost by this
course grading and this changed an idea
that had stood for many many years which
was that to make good judgments you need
people to remain independent they do not
need to influence one to each other
through conversations and actually when
people came back to their seats and they
had the opportunity to change their
minds this result was even much better
this is what you have here which is the
standard error of individual votes after
they have been filtered through
conversations so let me put all of this
together i showed you in the first part
that our decisions are very biased and
they have all these errors of reasoning
we only look at part of the evidence i
could not show all of them but i showed
enough to that i hope was convincing
that we make kind of these stereotype
errors
and they're a problem precisely because
they are stereotyped we are not aware of
them
and how can we be aware of them in the
moment you have to explain this to
someone else
so we asked what is it that people are
doing when they get together and what we
saw the first thing is that
like if you take all the results imagine
that you have a group like in the in the
number of cities and there's like a 400
or 480 and someone responded 700.
like the first thing you could do is
just average and this is good enough and
if you were to do this then you would
get the blue curve but the fact that the
black curve is better than the blue
curve is showing that the groups are
doing something better than average and
this is interesting because we did not
give groups any policy and yet it turns
out that groups are smarter than they
would be just by you know pulling their
information together in the most
classical way so if you look at all
possible mathematical models what you
get is that what people do is optimal
it's optimal statistically which is that
they tend to combine information of
everybody but they do so in a way that's
weighted by the confidence and so this
is this is a weighted average by which
you give more value to the person that
claims to know more and less value to
the person that actually claims to know
less
second typical robust statistical thing
is to identify where this is calibrated
so you try to see if the people that
have high confidence and this i do not
have enough time to dwell on we can go
into this into the question are kind of
impostors that we have the way people do
that is because they have high
confidence in all questions so if
someone claims to have high confidence
in all questions then the group do not
use this confidence information but if
they do so on some questions but not
others then they begin to use
information and finally of course from
this average they filter out liars so if
someone would say that they're like like
a three million
cities more than one million with more
than one million people then groups
would say you know we do not take this
information the average because it would
completely destroy so this is
interestingly enough but if i look at
this information here but if i were to
put the confidence weighted average it
would be somewhere between the blue line
and the black line that people do even
better than that
people do even better than the best
mathematical model to combine the
results and the reason is that people do
not come by the results they come by
they they combine the methods by which
they reach those results so they discuss
well how did you think this problem and
then they go ah yeah but you made an
error because look in europe cities are
not so populated and they begin
questioning actually the arguments and
the reasons that were kind of hidden in
the unconscious and that becomes just
kind of a monitoring process by which
you make explicit all the arguments that
lead to this decision so
very simple but very powerful is a
healthy way of making good decisions and
avoiding these biases is just whenever
you have to make an important decision
you look so for someone else
cannot be 300 people because that's not
a good conversion conversation just to
be two or three or four people
ideally they have to think different
from you so that you will be forced to
explain them the reasonings that led you
to this particular choice and on doing
so you are very likely to find errors
that would have been remain completely
unconscious if you did not go through
this particular filtering process i i
like to tell you something else because
i mentioned the idea i could finish here
but i would like to tell you one more
experiment this is the one that we did
with that we also did it in a group of
ten thousand people and then we did a
ted with with with dan ariely and here
the question was very similar to the one
i just presented but it was not on
questions that have a ground truth but
in questions that actually
are more in the domain of morality or
ideology or politics those things that
we just strongly believe they are right
or wrong and those things that as i said
are very polarized and some people have
very strong arguments that make them
believe for a and some people have very
strong arguments that make them live for
b and apparently like there's no way an
even less and less way of putting this
together i would like to make sure the
claim that this is not
an kind of an inevitable phase of human
dialogue and human interactions it's
just a consequence of conversations
happening in the wrong space which is
typically the space of social networks
and the space of a lot of people
shouting at the same time i want to make
the claim scientific claim that when
people get together in small groups
then they become more economists they
become much more malleable and much more
open than they actually think they are
so the way we did this experiment is we
had dilemmas
and this is just one dilemma and you'll
see they're kind of uncomfortable these
dilemmas you can read them and so a
company offers a service that takes a
fertilized egg and sorry i'm not seeing
the right part because
yeah and produces millions of embryos
with genetic variation this allows
parents to have a child that shares
their combined genomes at the same time
selecting their child's height eye color
intelligence social competence another
non-health related issue what the
competency does is and then you you can
say it's right or it's wrong according
to your beliefs each one has a position
people feel strongly about we had some
that were like even much more strongly
especially when they touch very
practical thing and very actual things
of of of human ideology
and and i'm of course not interested in
any moral conversation of this i'm just
interested in what goes on in the
decision process that makes us conclude
what we conclude each person will make a
different conclusion
and the idea that we may be more
malleable and that all of us may be not
seeing as much of the space of
argumentations that we think we are and
that we when we get together with
someone that thinks differently then we
may change more than we thought this is
what i will try to show you i have three
slides to make this so this was the
distribution of this particular
population this was an ed this is
nothing universal it will change in
different with people of different ages
people in different places just kind of
norm so you see a lot of people who are
very zero means like this completely
wrong and you see this here that means
it's completely right and you see that
in the same space with people that more
or less have the same background and so
on you have this diversity of someone
sitting next to other another one that
one thinks that it's completely wrong
and the other one thinks it's completely
right and the question is we will put
these people together in a group
is it and we will ask them to think like
they're in an ethical committee and
their job is to come up with a consensus
number for this like saying well we give
it a four we give it a six like it's not
completely right but it's it's
and the important thing is it has to be
unanimous
so it's three people the three of them
have to sign the paper and say i think
this is a this is the right thing to do
and they all have the option of saying
no i do not want to sign this and they
have this kind of opt-out and so the
question we're asking here is not so
much to what
consensus they reach as the question
before although we also ask this
question but the first interesting
question here is what is the likelihood
that they will reach consensus
and for this something that you have to
know which is important is that people
in the same way that they distribute
their opinions on whether it's right or
wrong they also distribute their
confidence in a way that is kind of
predictable which is that people that
are in the extremes they're very sure of
the position and the people in the
middle which we call the grace they
doubt more they are not sure and so
typically their confidence is way lower
but you may see here something which
actually is true in all the dilemmas
it's small but it's true which is the
people in this center in the very center
we have higher confidence and this is
because there is a bimodal distribution
in which there is a population of people
that are in this center but have very
high confidence
confidence and we call these people the
high confident grace those are the
people that
think you know this dilemma has
real reasons for being right real
reasons for being wrong and i'm really
sure that the right thing to do is to
stand somewhere in a central place
in
in this space of options
so
here you have like the distribution of
confidence for people some people have
medium confidence and these are the high
confidence rates so now
my last slide
what happens when we put these people
together and of course the likelihood
and the question is what is the
likelihood that they will reach a
consensus
and
of course if they we do this as a
function of their initial disagreement
and of course if the initial
disagreement is zero meaning that they
have the same ideas then they naturally
reach a consensus it's very simple you
think it's wrong i think it's wrong or
you think it's right i think it's right
we just signed the paper and we go out
very rapidly
and of course as there's more difference
this decreases that's natural no nothing
i mean nothing nothing that that
i mean it's highly expected
the real surprise
is that this value even with very high
disagreement is close to 50 percent it
varies in the question goes from 20 to
60 percent
but it's always one order of magnitude
higher than what people think if we ask
them is the likelihood that they will
reach an agreement so if i were to run
this experimentally and i would ask
which we've done and ask people what do
you think is the likelihood that if i
put someone that thinks this is
completely right with someone that
thinks it's completely wrong like if i
build 100 of this group how many will
reach agreement people will say one two
sometimes zero
and
reality is that in the right condition
people speaking and listening in an open
situation and not too many people
shouting then the likelihood of getting
together of agreeing to a consensus and
to depolarizing is much higher than what
people would expect once again
conversations converge to rationality
and not to rationality when they are in
their natural habitat in the right
domain and the last thing is
okay 50 of the groups but what is it why
some do and some don't and the answer to
this is the most important factor is
whether there is a high confident gray
if there's someone in the group that can
speak to both parties and say you know
you're right but you're also right and
look what he's or what she's saying may
have some reason because so there's
someone that understands
that it's not idiots against
intelligence in whatever side you want
to see the balance going but people with
arguments from both sides then the
likelihood of convergence is it
increases substantially you see not a
huge effect it's not like they guarantee
that there is likelihood of of consensus
but
they increase this very substantially
these experiments have been done
so this is a laboratory experiment but
many people have done these experiments
in the grounds i think the most
interesting experiments are done in the
frontier between israel and palestine
with the exact same results you put
together in the moment of most ferocious
fights in a situation where you think
there's no way these people you know
will understand you put like the most
radicals from one place and the most
radical from the other place and you
make them talk and if there's a high
confident gray that actually gives this
perspective of malleability the idea
that you know what take out of your mind
that your people will not change they
may change because you're thinking in
this way then uh groups now in in in in
the real ground not in this kind of
moral simulated experiments are much
more likely
to reach consensus and not only that but
also if you measure the likelihood of of
participating together in collaborative
work in working the same enterprises
future behavior of these people
it's a complete game changer so i think
there's something interesting out close
with this but i began with very
sophisticated technology you know fmri
to go into vegetative state patients and
and pre-verbal infants and so on and how
this can help us you know give us
information to make very difficult
decisions then i went on to say well you
know but this is on the majority of
decisions of course these decisions
happen just very rapidly fast and
furious decisions and we make all this
sort of errors and in the end i mean
instead of going skeptic on this
direction which i think we've been very
skeptical i wanted to give up a note not
from faked optimism but you know
data that we've been gathering for many
years that i think should give us at
least the idea that this pessimism of
the incapacity of conversations to solve
situation comes from the fact that
typically we have them in the wrong
setups and not where they should be so
with this i thank you very much and i'll
take all the questions that you may want
and thank you very much
thank you very much mariano for that
fantastic talk um
i have lots of questions myself uh but
uh we open up to uh the audience please
uh feel free to type your questions in
the q a and as people get ready um
if i may um i'd like to ask the first uh
question
so i really really liked your point
about how some of these conversations
are sort of happening in the wrong
spaces and that we need to find
smaller groups where sort of more
malleable opinions can actually be heard
but i was curious from what you say it
sounds like you know the success in sort
of this convergence and consensus making
requires a few persuasive mediators who
can talk to both sides so right so how
do we inculcate
such a temperament how do we get
people to be more sort of
that to have that frame with which they
see issues do you think it's in uh in
educational systems we can do something
or as a society or is it really an
individual
uh yeah this this is a i think a very
good and and
from my view at least very relevant
question it's been it's been very highly
studied
um
mostly as as you
bring in your intuition in educational
setups
so this is typically referred as as
malleable minds or growth minds is the
typical term like if you were to look in
like google scholar or for references
the right term would be a mind of growth
or growth mind and the typical problem
is it's like you give a 10 year old
children a problem that's just about
what they can do so they cannot solve it
and and that's typical of science right
in science we get problems that are just
above from what we can do
and
children split of course there's a
continuous but but they typically split
in in two modes of reaction it's not a
completely categorical split but there
are like two
tendencies
one is is frustration saying like i
cannot do it i mean it's too hard and
this leads to a whole lot of behaviors
they cheat
they blame others for giving them things
that they cannot do so they they they
build anger and so on and other children
naturally i mean this and those things
vary as as you know their variances in
height and eye color and so on there's
variance also in this disposition other
children understand that they cannot do
it but understand that they can
get close to it and that that's why it's
a
mind as a mind setup of growth because
they understand that they can do
something to break this leap between
where they are and where they have to be
and so this this stretches them so same
problem
to the two very different trajectories
and what has been like once again widely
studied in educational setups is that
this ends up being very decisive in
educational trajectory so children that
do have these mindsets
they persist in them and they start also
to buy 4k because they start
being outsiders and the ones that do not
pass the exams and the ones that start
believing that they cannot do things and
they belong here and so on well the
other ones are the ones that end up
going to the good schools and so on
now what the the good news is that
and that that's the response to your
question is that these things can be
changed there's
it's not easy but it's also not so hard
so it's not
but it's not so easy i mean it's not
just a disposition it's not just like
saying i want to have an open mindset
and then bloom next day you will have it
we have kind of these cognitive
illusions but this is not true for any
form of learning it's not like i want to
play tennis the next day you play tennis
you have to train it
in the same way if if you want to have
an open mindset you have to train it but
it's much easier than playing tennis
that's the good news i mean it takes you
know some and there are many different
ways
that have been developed once again
mostly in educational setups and it's
been proved that if children in time you
change them
a fixed mindset to an open or to a
growth mindset then they they are in
time
to uh
to have a
better likelihood those things of course
are always probabilistic but they they
have a a
higher probability
of a having going through a much better
educational trajectory
um thank you but so it sounds like this
has to be instilled as an aspiration
even for the kids that don't naturally
have that temperament and this is why
yeah it has to be you have to and and
and this is train it also
many times parents
because
it's it's not like it's not something
that you have to learn because some
people have it granted right and other
people don't so it's not like there's a
default for this and then you can go
back on on why this happens and and some
of these things may be genetic and so on
but some of these are also very early
implicit training so parents building
this mentality in ways not not in ways
that they understand it sometimes
completely against their their will and
their desire
um
so there are there are different things
this is a very complicated literature so
it's not like there's a simple way on on
how to build this mentality i'm i think
i'm i'm pointing you to the idea and and
it requires study i think i it would not
be fair if i say i can summarize this in
two minutes but some ideas we can we can
we can put in the table one that has
been known pedagogy for a long time is
people get frustrated when they have
aspirations which are ridiculously high
and and and different educational setups
work differently in this condition so
one condition is you're always kind and
there's a very uh
a
famous pedagogical idea by by lev
bigotsky
which is the
the sound of proximity so it's the idea
that learning
has to be just above but just above in
these problems that i told you they are
not just about they're like like a
significant step above so those are the
ones that can frustrate you and that's
not where you should
typically have children grow in their
educational setup so this is one reason
that will make a lot of children
make the conclusion that they cannot
solve problems which are more difficult
than they can afford because they've
given problems that they really could
not solve because they were so difficult
that they have made this conclusion
because of a wrong sampling history of
problems so so this is i mean this is
just one idea of of how you can begin
biasing falling in one side of the camp
or government it's complex
but there's substantial literature and i
think that it's one of the cases in
which we can make
a
informed policies both at like large
public policies but also in parental
policies like how to grow our children's
in a better way
um thanks mariano it also sounds like
this is the kind of thing that you would
have to persistently reinforce as well
you would have to keep reinforcing yeah
yeah and also
that's why i'm i'm making always the
point when it's complex it's also domain
specific
so some children may have they they may
have some domains in which they have
this mentality and they know they can
solve them
but they are bad in maths
and so suddenly in math so as i was
saying in tuition it's not like there's
people with good intuition
people
have different ways of relating with
adversity and with resilience in
different domains and then one thing
which is also very important to know is
that
and this comes from from from a very
basic idea of of of of so i said
i i made the case that we
make very rapid conclusions which we
trust a lot but it's even worse than
that because then these conclusions
begin changing us on a way that we
confirm the conclusions that we've made
and this happens individually but also
socially because we tend to look for
data that confirms the hypothesis that
we have already made so imagine you're
in a point of view for occasion where
you can make the like the claim i'm bad
at math or i'm good at math and you're
right there and you'll make your claim
once you it's like a bit like like
measurements in quantum physics once
you've you've made this call and you say
i'm bad at that
then you've changed reality
it's it's and because once you've made
this call
this is this is what i i like uh soros
george soros the the the finance uh you
know he was a stud
he studied with popper and his he knows
a lot of human behavior and this is why
he's made a lot of money in because he
understands how people behave in a very
deep way and it's interesting because
the way i think he thinks of the stock
market as the best laboratory of human
behavior
and he keeps on coming on this idea
which he calls reflexivity so the new
idea it's an old idea but it's very
powerful and he says that this is one of
the central ideas in the market is the
market makes a belief
that that an action is going the stock
is going to grow
and this decision that the market has
made changes reality in the way that now
this this stock changes because people
will be consistent with the idea that
they've made so this leads to financial
bubbles there's a moment in which there
is an inconsistency between between
people's beliefs and reality and then
there's kind of an explosion the idea i
would like to bring here is that we also
have the psychological bubbles like we
tell to ourselves a story i'm good at
this or i'm bad at this and this story
builds because we sample data in a way
that we look for consistency on that
eventually sometimes it also blows but
for a long time it gives us the ability
of having completely different
mentalities
so this is also important sometimes
parents they are not also aware like
sometimes statements are very heavy like
saying he's not good at math you know or
he's a
like i'll tell you what that happens to
me like my son he's the one that tends
to he he falls a lot i mean he's you
know they're cheating this is all the
typical behavior so like if they're they
go to up to a party birthday party and
one falls and and has like an ache in
his hand typically it's my son because
he's kind of not the best control and so
on
and
sometimes i'm very versed on this but
sometimes i i make the error
of you know making kind of the
caricature of this you know making fun
of these and making oh once again it's
you know like like
when
with this i know theory tells me that i
should never do this because the only
thing i'm doing is i'm fueling more
something
that actually is
begins being self-consistent so what i'm
saying with this is that
sometimes there are very strong biases
that very are difficult to eradicate
they take like substantial
uh attentional control
and not to fall onto these errors that
parents often fall to stigmatize even
their children which is the last thing
they would want to do on earth but
sometimes we do never do this
really insightful thank you so much
mariano um going back to something
earlier in your presentation uh from one
of our frequent participants jenny she
asks is the buba kiki correspondence a
form of synesthesia and if so does this
tell us that everybody is capable of
developing synesthesia yeah yeah so uh
yes it is so for for for those that may
not be familiar with the word
synesthesia means that there's kind of a
automatic relation between different
sensory modalities
and
so some people when they see some shapes
they they they as we saw here they
believe that they correspond to certain
sounds but there is also some people
that
when they perceive certain tastes these
states produce certain sounds or they
relate to certain shapes so
vision audition taste smell which
normally are independent modalities
they're automatically linked
and what this experiment shows is that
we all have certain forms of synthesis
some of those are cultural for instance
another example would be color and
temperature
most of us think i mean those things a
priori are independent but they're not
and the reason they're not is because
they're a material correspondent which
is the majority of materials when
they're incandescent
and hence they're warm they're red
and so we tend to think that red is hot
and that blue which is more the color of
of ice
is is cold and this is a form of
cultural synesthesia which is driven
by a
by
material experience like the one i i
showed with the mouth another example
which i really really like and it's it's
in in my book priya which which you you
mentioned
and so you may have read about it is the
correspondence between time and space
which
a priori are different entities but the
majority of the people and if you think
like how we use language is you feel
like christmas is approaching it's
approaching from where like like it's
christmases and time but we have the
feeling that it's ahead of us it
features a head and the past is behind
and this seems like that's just how it
has to be like kiki and buba but there
are other cultures i mentioned example
of
the imalas which is a culture in the in
the in the northwest of argentina and
bolivia and chile and this culture has
in their language the word for in front
also means past it's the same word and
the word for behind which is naida also
means in the front and it's very
interesting because they might as what
they say is that the reason the past is
in front is it's because it's the only
thing we know
and there's this relation between what
like when when you want to tell someone
did you understand someone you say you
see you see it like seeing is
understanding seeing is knowing and so
if you use this relation the only thing
you see the only thing you know the only
thing you understand is the past
and the things that you do not see you
do not understand and you do not know is
the future with hence is behind it's in
the back
and so it's very interesting because
we believe that like this correspondence
in aesthetic correspondence between time
and space seems very logical like the
future you know we advance to the future
that's how it should be but someone
comes in a different culture then you
know what for me it's the other way
around and there are many other ones
like the aztecs they have circular time
and so now it's not only different
correspondence between what's ahead and
what's behind but also in the topology
of space interestingly there's also not
complete freedom because
all cultures known
use a one-dimensional representation for
spade for for for time and and that's
very interesting because it seems to be
as far as we can tell from the way we
perceive time that this is a physical
limitation of how we can you know we can
organize a certain space so there are
many many examples of of synesthesia
also very interesting just to tell an
anecdote i think maybe because edward
hubbard and ramachandra which i
mentioned in their paper they are they
were kind of the founders of the
neuroscience of non-founders but kind of
doing a lot of the interesting words the
work of of the neuroscience of
synesthesia a network however was it was
we did some work together and we were
very good friends and the problem with
working with synesthetes is that it has
this flair of genius
right so musicians they claim
that they see
music and this gives brie brilliancy you
know it's like or mathematicians you
know a great mathematician will tell you
i can hear the sound of pie you know and
and hence i'm you know like i'm i'm not
just like uh
the product of work i'm the product of
genius because i have like this very
sophisticated so it gives a kind of a
sense of poetry so people lie on this
and so you get a lot of people that come
to the laboratory saying that they're
synaesthetes which they're not and
they're very interesting tests to to
measure whether someone is genuinely uh
synesthetic or not for instance one is
typical synesthesia is people see
letters of different colors so like else
will be blue and a's will be red
and and so you say okay perfect so now
do the following
and you give them a mace which is full
of l's and there's one a
and if you're not seeing this is very
hard because it requires a lot of
attention but if it's red on green then
this just pops out and it's very rapid
so some people are real synesthetes and
these people they just you know can find
it you know in a fraction of a second
independently of how many destructors
there and so on well so people claim
their synesthetes but then in truth and
there are many many more interesting
stories about synesthesia but you could
go very long that's uh fantastic so
there's a question from uh victoria
who asks
how has information from the
myers-briggs personality evaluation been
incorporated into any of these studies
can you repeat the question because i'm
not sure i understood it the information
from the myers-briggs personality
evaluation
has been has that been incorporated into
any of these studies
i i don't know sorry i i i'm not i i i
don't know
yeah there are these personality tests
that you can take that cast you into
certain combinations yeah but i i this
is a research i would not like to speak
about something that i i i'm sure there
is information on that but not that i'm
aware and i i that's that's kind of the
limit of my knowledge i i
no
i'm nobody i i would be i would be
speaking colloquially that that's not
something that i know sufficiently to
provide an informed answer i'm very
sorry
um no worries one of our fellows tyler
lutz asks are there still confident gray
positions
for situations in which there is no
natural middle point
what happens for instance if you ask
groups to point towards vladivostok
or guess in what direction the hour hand
on the clock there is pointing
yeah this is very interesting um
this is this is very interesting because
uh
we we've we've not done the confident
grace on problems
like this sword that have a uh
concrete and
real ground truth there's a solution and
and they have particular distributions
where
where
their gaussians they may be shifted or
we the the confident grades are i think
interesting in problems in which the
distribution of beliefs is typically by
model
and and and we've shown actually in a
specific paper that
how people
build confidence on these problems and
how people build confidence on
perceptual problems like pointing to
bloody was talk
leads to very different distributions
which leads to very different ways in
which confidence is being constructed
and essentially the main distribution
the main difference has to do with the
idea of from what's the universe from
which they sample data and typically in
in polarized problems
it is as if this is a model so this this
is this is a very simplified model so
that i'm not speaking exactly how it
works in our brain but a model in which
you
let people sample from two
different distributions arguments so you
have arguments like imagine like imagine
the the genetic problem i gave so
arguments in favor would be you know we
try to make the best for our children
and when we use the arguments we have we
use education why not use genetics i'm
not saying this is right i'm saying this
is an argument an argument against would
be
like
this will lead to you know
aryan like the kind of typical
eugenic uh nightmare right so we will
all converge to monochromatic
humans and
what i'm trying to say is that those
arguments you see they're very discreet
and i could beat many more but they seem
to be picked from their very different
paths and and so it builds a very my
model distribution in which you may have
a number of arguments from this bag and
a number of words from this bag and then
people that are the high confident grace
are the one that actually sample from
both of them the ones that are below
confidence grades are the ones that
actually
have very low sampling so essentially
they don't understand the problem and
they think it's just
too complicated and they don't want to
think about it it's a very different
perspective
so
i don't think the high confident gray
argument would work for unimodal
distributions like in the problem uh i
forgot the name he or she mentioned
likely pointing to global stock problems
that are typically perceptual problems
this has not been shown and i don't
think it would work there i think the
intuition is right
i think we have a good reason to to
understand why it would not work which
is is again its confidence is
constructed very very very differently
in this kind of problems
thank you next question from the
audience can you tell us something more
on the shaping of reality generated by a
claim that we do
it seems that we convince ourselves of
something and then we subconsciously
make decisions that confirm the claim
yeah
so the
let me give you an example because i
mentioned the wrong conversations from
twitter and so on
there are a lot of correlations between
the actions that we make and the beliefs
that we have so it's been known for
years that people like and actually we
just have a paper on these people like
other people that think like them
and and
this is very universal it's very
conserved of course
you should not take this argument as you
will not like someone that thinks
differently from you it's a statistical
argument that we tend to
to like more we tend to prefer and we
tend to have many many more friends
actually each of you in the audience can
do the experiment how many people
around you do you have that think
radically differently from you like like
in in first question second question
take 15 different problems like
you know
taxes abortion
drugs
foreign policy i mean take a number of
them and think how you think about all
of them and think how the majority of
the people think about these people and
if you're like the majority of people
you'll find a very strong correlation so
you do agree on a lot of problems that
when you think about them
they are really independent problems i
mean me being liberal on this does not
imply that i have to be liberal on this
and i can be conservative of this other
but we tend to be kind of very partisan
and we tend to be when i say we tend is
a statistical finding that the vast
majority of the people
are like this interestingly those are
experiments in sociology the more
educated the people they are the more
correlated they are so if you take in
the us the axis of
what democrats think about a particular
problem what's like the typical democrat
reaction to any particular problem and
what's the typical republican uh this is
20 years ago now republican i mean it
spreads in axis but typically when
really there was like a two-dimensional
layout of of political spread mostly of
the most of the guardians in the u.s
then and then you spread people in this
in these domains and you ask how much
people look alike how correlated they
are
and you measure this as a function of
education the more educated people they
are the more correlated they are the
more they begin to think alike because
they they they form describes in which
why is this this is a response to your
question because
they they are intelligent people we are
i mean i speak in third person but i i
make all these errors i mean i'm not
excluded from any of these and
but we tend to listen
arguments
that we
unconsciously gather to confirm our
beliefs because this is very comfortable
how this happens there's a very we did
one study which i think at least to me
it was very enlightening on the
complexity of this problem because
this is true of course this is worse in
social networks because people in social
networks follow who they want to follow
and so they get a lot of evidence that
confirms what they want to do which is
true i mean take vaccines i mean i'm i'm
vaccinated and i'm completely in favor
of accidents here i'm going to say my
collar it's not important but
if there's information some information
that shows that vaccines do have a risk
and and the obvious fact for this is
that for instance we
i'm sure i want to vaccinate myself i do
not think i would like to vaccinate a
six month old baby
and this is just a recognition that i
understand that there are arguments
against it
in my opinion the arguments in favor are
much more sound and hence i make my
conclusion but i'm not but if i only
were to look at these arguments and this
is the once again the only space i'm
looking for i will rationally make a
conclusion that this is the wrong thing
to do because i do have papers and
evidence that show all what i want to
see that proves that i have to stand
where i do stand
so how does this work in social networks
there are fact checking companies that
understood this problem and so they said
we need to provide balanced evidence we
need to pronounce evidence showing that
like the good people do good things the
good people do bad things the bad people
do good things and the bad people do
good things so that people understand
that reality is more complex perfect now
what happens you can see this as kind of
a distribution of evidence right so even
in favor even by mobile evidence i was
saying those you could think about
vaccines you know you should vaccinate
because of this but you should worry
because of it but you should do it
because of this but beware with that but
and it's providing all the evidence now
what is the problem the problem is that
these companies have like say 1 million
followers but then the followers of
these companies
retweet or reshare the information that
they get to 50 million people and these
50 million people do not receive
directly from the fact-checking company
they receive it from who they want to
receive it so it's kind of like a
rectifier so this company is is showing
information balance information but then
there are rectifiers social rectifiers
that filter information and only let
this one pass black plug and there are
people that are downstream from these
rectifiers because they have this belief
they have the belief that vaccines are
wrong so they only follow people that
provide information that confirm this
vaccine and they get more and more
convinced
and once again i want to make the claim
it's not like they are thinking wrong
they are thinking on the wrong subset of
the data
there and this is this is wrong but
restricted to this particular constraint
the conclusions that they often make are
right are the right conclusions from
just looking at a small subset of the
data so this is a very clear example of
how once you have a belief
you decide to sample data on a way that
only confirms that the belief that you
had and you gather real data that
actually will prove more and more that
you are right to think that
right and even when you have a broader
set of data available you gravitate
towards the bits of data
yeah this is also very typical that even
exactly this this is very important that
you're saying people and this comes from
the even i mean
and this is we tend to think this as
irrationality but this is in the essence
of science when when we make like the
typical scientific claim of of great
claims imply
or require great evidence like if i want
to say that the speed of light is not
constant then
i really should have a lot of evidence
why because we have a strong belief a
strong prior in if you think this has
variation thinking like i do have a lot
of aggregated knowledge that tells me so
if i do have information of the same
value in favor of what i have a strong
prior and against what i have a strong
prior
priyas you are saying i will not weigh
them in the same manner this is exactly
what you would expect from a rational by
asian thinker this is the thing to do
so um there's one more question that i
want to take which sounds intriguing so
uh the question is from brad uh in the
audience he says you know thank you so
much for your presentation so your
response to that mba question about
personality types
uh made him curious and he wants to know
how has your work been received by
psychologists working on emotional
intelligence so the president of our
university peter salovey is one of the
sort of originators of this idea of eq
uh and emotional um intelligence
yes so
this this is what i mean what i
mentioned there is is not my work so so
i today i was i was kind of careful of
saying what part of the research i
showed was was my work the work on the
papers the papers and decision making
where am i work but then the extension
of these two educational setups in
malleability frameworks and so on it's
not it's not it's a lot of famous people
have done this but this is this is not
my work we've done work in education
um
showing
same ideas but but but not exactly this
now in terms of of
so i don't know the answer like the
answer is is that because this is not my
work i i know exactly how it would be
received by but because i
would like to respond i i kind of want
to respond agent tangently to this
question to something that i think is a
bit related
um
[Music]
emotional intelligence like like uh like
general intelligence like iqs or eqs
they're very controversial and
i think we'll understand the reasons
like like for instance now there's
there's a
group of researchers that the i think
that the
champion of this
research would be lisa feldman barrett
uh she has a a a very interesting book
called how emotions are made and i think
she would be a very good speaker for
for this symposium
uh
she makes the claim she makes a very
strong claim that emotions are
completely different than
than the way we think about them
and in particular she makes the claim
that in the same way that i told you
that you know we think that the future
has to be ahead and the past has to be
behind
that we think that you know
this has to be anger and this is
happiness
and and she claims that this is wrong
like and she claims this from data it's
not it's not a and and her data is that
actually if you look at the typical
tests used for emotional intelligence
which is our ability to separate this
from uh i know
from from
you know this that would be sadness a
are kind of very strong cultural
conventions that have very
fussy
mappings much much much more fuzzy than
it has been claimed they are different
in different cultures it's she claims
it's not true that all babies express
them and understand them it's not true
that so there's kind of a controversy
and this controversy comes
in the end i think
in an issue of definitions my point
there
both for iq and for emotional
intelligence my understanding
is kind of a
broad view of all the data and i think a
and and
and i think that all the data shows
consistently that there's some some
[Music]
consistency between how people express
emotions in different cultures and in
different traditions and in different
ages and different backgrounds
but also
it's not completely universal there are
exceptions there are very clear
excursions lisa feldman has a very nice
example she shows the face of serena
williams when she won the u.s open and
she's like
and if you see that she's like really
angry but she's not angry she's an
ecstasy and she says like
like the intensity of the emotion we
confuse them and we can kind of of of
reappraise this emotion and
re-understand it and re-signify it in a
completely different way so
i think i think that that that the
my impression
um
and and here i'm saying my impression
because before i was saying i think what
the paper said but now it's just it's a
it's a space in which the paper say
different thing this happens many times
in science
and when this is the case i think that
you have to
understand
that there's
more variability
and more complexity in the distributions
and
more lack
of understanding and clear definitions
that makes
that builds this incompatibility so this
may be sorry a bit of a long answer but
it is it goes down to say
that i think that that part of the of
kind of a very big discussions between
these fields
in the end are because we do not have
yet mature
and good definitions of what an emotion
is of what sadness is of what emotional
intelligence is
and so
whatever attempt someone makes to do it
like the examples you were making or
like like ekman and and all the all the
the famous examples
are prone to failure like all science i
myself i'm very sympathetic because i
think they need to be done and it's an
approximation and they will fail like
all scientific models have failed and
this one are more likely to fail against
because the territory is more
this more is is highly variable
and and so i think we have to pursue
this direction
but not stubbornly but understanding
that as all scientific model is the best
approximation that we have it's kind of
kind of the best that we can do with the
data we have we hold it we have to be
open like once again malleable and
understand that we have not to stick
religiously to it because it's our baby
model and the one we constructed but in
the moment that it does does not hold to
the evidence and there's sufficient
contradiction that we need a better
model then it's time eventually to
change
yeah no i think you've captured very
nicely sort of the you know the
provisional nature of knowledge in
science basically what you know at any
given time is the best to date
and has limitations and you have to be
aware of the limitations and therefore
you have to be willing to change your
mind as you get better data more
evidence as you said you know you have
to build a more refined conceptual model
so i um
i could keep going on i have so many
more questions but i think we need to
close with one final question
uh which is um jenny wagner asking again
following up on the bifurcation of
decisions is there any neurological
reason
why any change of decision after the
first one has been taken
happens more often abruptly instead of
slowly
for example going suddenly feeling being
good at maths after all when having
solved one difficult problem
yeah i'm not sure i uh so
there are two i i saw two different
answers to this question i'm not sure
either of them is the exact one but so
one thing is
there's a lot of because you mentioned
like like the brain evidence and so far
i've been speaking about psychological
evidence
so there's a lot of
neural evidence for all what i've been
describing and this comes from a kind of
a way that a lot of
neuroscience has changed in the last
years
in how decision making
progresses which is on a highly
variation
uh
strategy so there are many many
demonstrations alex puget for instance
in geneve would be i think that the best
person to look for for this kind of
information showing that you can account
for a lot of strange things in decision
making if you look at the neural
circuits as doing variation a
computations and this this is the
essence of of kinds of this
self-fulfilling prophecy because it's
you make a prior and once you make a
prior you sample evidence priya as you
exactly described it in an in an
unbalanced manner so so so
so there is no evidence showing that
once you've committed to a decision
then neural circuits change in a way
that they decide differently it's not a
magical construction it's a this is
implemented in a way that we understand
in neurons the second thing is this idea
that then there's kind of a role of of
of these decisions being much faster
and here i think
at least what comes to mind to me i'm
not sure this is exactly the answer
you're looking for but this
there's
people have studied this very nicely in
the history of of world sport records
so
there are many records that have not
been broken for years and years and
years and years and then eventually
they're broken and once they're broken
there's like a very rapid repetition
so
like the cleanest example is is running
one mile in less than four minutes i
think that's the which was kind of off
of
no one could do it and then 40 years ago
someone did it and since then there's
like 1400 people
here that have done it but before that
for 40 years no one did it and so of
course there's an issue of technology
but it's not only technology because
it's really this this game changer this
revocation and and one the explanation
for this once again is only the force of
the mind of our own minds to convince
ourselves of what we can do and what we
cannot do and i would like to temper
this because it's not like i say i want
to fly and then i fly like this this is
by no means it it's obvious but i want
to state it i mean it's it's not i'm not
predicating here that dream about
something and it will come true this
this is not the case people live in very
bad realities and and they struggle and
they cannot do better than they do
but there's
this said there's much more margin than
we think
for the range of beliefs for the reasons
i just explained in our own performances
and in our own decisions on a way that
once we understand that something is
doable and so they believe that it could
not be done is eradicated then this is a
game changer that then builds on a rapid
cascade of so this is an example from
social sciences so to say but i think
it's it's the best example for the
psychological question that you were
asking
great
thank you so much that
just absolutely fascinating talk and
thank you so much for taking the time so
to thoughtfully answer
all these questions
i really should uh draw it to a close
because we uh are over our time um thank
you so much
once again for uh coming and giving us
this wonderful talk very thought
provoking and hopefully we all leave
here aspiring to have as malleable a
mind as possible right
uh to make our ways in the world thank
you so much so
let's uh give mariano a real round of
applause virtual loss yes
thank you thank you so much priya
thank you
thank you